oh
oh my god
oh
oh my god
welcome back to the iced coffee hour i'm
beau hightower and this podcast has made
2.137 million dollars what a guess no
214 000 not quite it's ad revenue yeah
ad revenue okay yeah but anyway so much
for going on man i've been really
looking forward to this so i've watched
your content from like three years ago
i hate to say it but i would just be
like back cracking guy on youtube and
seeing the most incredible videos of
just like contorting people and then
their their whole body cracks in a way
that
i can't even explain it it becomes
addicting where you want to just keep
watching like the asmr for this and i'm
thinking how can i do that
how did you get started doing this and
not only that but like your content has
gone crazy viral over these last like
three years has it been yeah roughly
well let's see
i was born in a cold hospital in 1983.
no long story short i uh i was an
athlete all the way growing up you know
early mid 90s um big football fan the
the 49ers in particular in the cowboys
also they had a team cairo and it would
show up on like the the fox you know
news spots about them like jerry rice
and joe montana so my dad started taking
me to go to one in high school when i
was playing football and it made a
really big difference for me um so after
college you know i was a biology major
to start with and i was trying to figure
out do i want to continue into biology
do i want to work for like u.s fish and
wildlife
because i really enjoyed getting out in
nature and doing like you know
groundwater chemistry and and you know
turbidity readings and things like that
yeah not really great for your bottom
line yeah um so i'm like okay what am i
going to do my dad is a home builder so
not really interested in that at all and
then his dad sold carpet so we just have
like a lot of different
business interests in the family and so
i think there was a like a flyer in the
um the professions office where it was
like you know applied to pharmacy school
cairo school pt school so i started
shadowing different people and the pt's
that i shouted were
um they were kind of older folks it just
didn't feel like my niche and then i
went back to my chiro from my youth and
he had a bunch of high school athletes
on he was playing golf i was like you
know that looks like a pretty a pretty
good career path for me so went to cairo
school um had practices in dallas san
antonio
cincinnati and then i finally resettled
in albuquerque about 10 years ago
and so i've been working with mma
fighters in an mma gym for about a
little over a decade now
and uh basically what had happened was i
got banned from instagram in 2018 um for
reposting ufc videos they were really
trying to clean up all their content at
the time so they were ip copyright
striking everybody in the world and i
got like six in a row on instagram so
they've completely deleted my notes okay
and that's where i grown like a
following first like fighters promoting
me and things like that so i had you
know at the time maybe 250 000 on ig
that's pretty good so didn't have any on
youtube um
and so you know i'm used to uploading
stuff and so i started throwing some of
my videos up on youtube and next thing i
knew it had like 1.8 million two million
views and um i just got lucky i was on
the front edge of the cairo tube wave
you know there was the i've never heard
of that
there's finance tube right there's gun
tube and there's cairo tube is kyra too
big yeah it's it's decreased now but
it's big yeah there's several
several there's one it's got over two
million subs okay but there's a lot that
are over a million so there's like four
or five that were really big at the time
that we're posting um and it was kind of
like the pimple popping thing people
were just like whoa what's that like
those crunchy sounds and it was just
something yeah really seen a lot before
i've seen that what is it the pimple
doctor the pimple popping doctor
whatever it is she's cute on instagram
it keeps coming up recommended and i
don't want to watch it but i have to i
have to watch it all the way through yep
and she's rich yeah she has a tlc show
really oh yeah so it's kind of the same
thing so i was lucky to be one of those
first four or five
people it was really popping off and
then algorithmically i had fighters so
there's ufc fans that are watching it
too yeah um so it just kind of popped
off and then ever since then we're like
all right let's keep this content going
and how do we keep it fresh and
interesting so what do you think makes
people enjoy watching content of you
cracking people's body and contorting it
so much what's so special about it i
mean i think what we just talked about
um
in the asmr era
turns out subconsciously there's a lot
of things that psychologically we like
some things we don't like so if you ever
see have you ever seen the mildly
infuriating or
mildly infuriating reddit yeah yeah well
i know what you're talking about yeah
like they cut the pizza in the wrong
slices and they mark outside the lines
and they go to break glass but don't
actually show the the break yeah so
there's something in us where
and somebody has done this too where
they start to do the adjustments and
they don't do the crack and it's like
infuriating so there's something
something subconsciously about
a sound being released and completion
maybe of a task
that we like and um i think like you
said along the lines of pimple popping
it's satisfying to see like a blackhead
come out um there's something primal and
nobody really knows but subconsciously
about us watching somebody's body do
that and make those kinds of sounds i'm
curious is it ever dangerous because
half the times i see like uh you did the
grandma the instrument uh what is the
tick-tock grandma
and i think she's in her 80s or 90s and
you're sitting there like holding her
head like
like jolting her head like i'm ever
worried is there ever a risk that like
you snap the wrong way and it just goes
horribly wrong yeah there's always a
risk to anything right there's a risk to
driving in the car drinking coffee but
statistically we know the relative risk
so as long as you're doing a good
screening of the patient's medical
history i mean you're talking one per 10
20 million or something like that which
is about the same as sneezing or
coughing or you know going to jiu-jitsu
or boxing or anything like that so you
know
like boxing you saw the puerto rican
fighter that yeah a few years ago one
hit and has brain damage or whatever
everything carries a risk your
medications your ibuprofen you know
literally everything but it's about
making sure you're getting the the right
history and the right person and being
able to mitigate those as much as
possible got it so what exactly are you
doing when you take someone's neck and
you jolt it to the one side you hear a
crack what's going on beneath that so
what you're looking at if you looked at
a spine you've got vertebrae and then
you've got discs so like kind of space
in between and there's a bunch of
ligaments and muscles on the side well
in the corners there's these joints
called called zigopapa physial joints or
facet joints so those joints allow
gliding of the spine in different
directions
you know the middle part allows
resistance resistance mostly to
compression so what can happen is those
joints on the side get stuck they
basically overlay each other like that
when they get stuck you won't be able to
move very well you'll get pain in those
areas particularly over the joint line
so when you get a crack and you don't
have to get the crack for the removement
that just is
an indicator that you've reached full
range of motion
is basically that joint stretches far
enough to where the gas that's within it
dissolves and it basically pops the
bubble that's in there
and then that basically is the sound
that you're making so essentially by
getting the joint to end range you allow
that patient to move through their full
range of motion
so
that's super helpful in an acute patient
like say your rib is stuck or you have
an si joint that's stuck um but by and
large that's only one aspect of
treatment so now you've got full range
but how do you keep it there right if
they've been stuck for a while then they
need to make sure they're doing
stretches rehab exercises so they
maintain that range of motion so they
don't get locked up again yeah so one
morning i woke up a few months ago i had
the worst stiff neck i've ever had in my
entire life and i literally could not
move my head for an entire day i went on
youtube and i saw that it was more so
like muscle stretching how much of this
movement is muscle versus just the the
spine itself yeah and i don't think you
could ever really separate them from
each other um so that's what we call
torticollis or ryneck
this is something that spinal
manipulation is really good at there's a
lot of things that could cause a spasm
ligament strain facet joints strain
sprain disc bulges could do it
but typically if you haven't had a
trauma then you know it's probably not
like an acute disc herniation or a bulge
like something's landed on your head or
yeah so usually when that happens either
you've got a joint that stuck or you've
managed to strain one of the ligaments
then what happens your body tries to
protect itself so it spasms all the
muscles so when we do so so really what
i do is something called nephropathy so
nephropathy is treating ligaments and
muscles but also within that i also went
to chiro school as well so i have two
doctorates so combining those two things
i found gets the best results we loosen
up all the muscles we get in there we
break up the tissue and then we make
sure the joint has full range of motion
and they get their exercises and then
what's going on when you take the big
pin
and take the hammer and you're just like
knocking it that that seems painful yeah
it's so so you'll see in a few minutes
what seems painful is actually not and
then the opposite is also true right so
when you see me just like kind of
haphazardly touching a trigger point
yeah that's actually significantly more
painful
what we're doing there is we're either
tricking the muscle into the spindle
link so so like if i'm having them turn
their head and i'm tapping on the muscle
similar to a vibration plate we're
tricking the muscle and not knowing how
long it's supposed to be so it allows
you to pass through that in range of
motion of what the muscle spindle and
the the mechanoreceptors think it is
sometimes like with a pelvis say have
like a posterior tilt like your hip bone
tilts this way this is a pretty common
thing in pt and cairo what we're doing
is we're moving the top end forward and
the bottom end up so we're aligning you
that way and then of course we going to
loosen the hamstring so that it doesn't
pull it back down
so
sometimes we're using it to move a bone
in a specific direction sometimes we're
using to loosen muscles that's
incredible i've never been to a
chiropractor never ever oh man no i've
seen all the videos but i've never been
myself okay i'm curious how much did it
cost to to get yourself through school
well i have six college degrees in a
postdoc certificate so
probably cumulative somewhere in the 300
to 400 000 range do you still carry debt
from that no oh
that's it that seems like a lot um
is the roi better to go into
chiropractics because i would imagine
for 400 000 you could become you know
get into plastic surgery neuro surgery
like there's so many different ways you
could go with that that like right off
the bat you would get a salary like 400
grand well it's super
relative so like
cairo is more like pt or optometry or
podiatry more of the allied fields as
opposed to medical degrees right so
there's no there's no specialty as far
as your licensing goes in any of those
allied fields pharmacy as well you can
do more things like you could be a
clinical pharmacist or whatever but
basically pharmacy is one degree cairo's
similar so like i have 350 hours of
postdoc neuro education but that doesn't
change my scope of practice really
so essentially you do four years of
undergrad four years of chiro school
eight years and then you'd be a
chiropractor same on the property so
with med school you're gonna do four
years four years of med school and then
you have to do residency so that's what
people when they're looking at all these
things they have to decide because if
you're doing plastic surgery you're
looking at
a minimum of five years of residency
plus fellowship after that yeah and
you're gonna be making 60 70 grand a
year during that time and your debt is
accumulating and you're drawing interest
on that yes their salary will be
significantly higher later on but
they're also much further out as far as
opportunity cost whereas cairo's as soon
as they graduate they can practice right
away
but first we gotta thank our sponsor ftx
us now is a great time to buy crypto but
finding a reputable trustworthy exchange
isn't always easy that's why we
recommend that if you're gonna be buying
and selling crypto do what we do and use
ftx we both use the ftx app and we just
love how easy it is to use and how great
it looks and best of all when buying
crypto and nfts unlike other exchanges
that charge old big fees nasty fees fdx
has no fees whatsoever on all crypto and
nfts guys seriously that is like unheard
of in crypto exchanges to not charge
fees not to mention jack they're one of
the largest exchanges in the world with
millions of users he can't know this but
ftx is soon launching stocks and they're
going to be an all-in-one finance app
where you can trade stocks crypto nfts
all with no fees you could also do
recurring buys to dollar cost average
into the markets on a regular basis like
we do so start trading crypto and nfts
with no fees today with the link down
below in the description with the ftx
app plus you could get all the way up to
a hundred dollars of free crypto and
free crypto on every trade you make over
ten dollars again use the link down
below in the description start trading
crypto with no fees whatsoever thank you
so much ftx and back to the podcast that
being said i think the data if i look at
the statistics correctly cairo is the
worst debt to income ratio of any um any
degree that you can get how much do
chiropractors usually make i think the
median salary is about 70 75 000. is
that like entry level i think that's
cumulative i think that's everybody wow
probably a quarter of my class i think
doesn't practice anymore so they're
either in farm rep or oil or oh do a lot
of people they go into it and then go
into it yeah so it's a big broad like
umbrella so
you know a lot of people that
you know in certain faiths like we have
a lot of mormons that were in our chiro
school because you know they're just not
into pharmaceuticals or chemicals so
they find their way into a natural or
holistic field
um so a lot of people get in this one to
do nutrition or supplements or things
like that but of course insurance isn't
really covering that and you're not
going to get hired at a hospital on a
salary so you've got to go out there and
create a business so cairo and dentistry
are similar in that sense where there's
not a whole lot of jobs out there so you
have to be a business owner essentially
or start a business got it um where pt
you could you know you could get an
in-home
or an at-home job or salary it may not
be high but there's always a job for
cairo there's not a lot of jobs like in
new mexico i think there's one at the va
hospital one at kirtland air force base
one at unm and those are the only three
jobs in our entire city like a salaried
getting insurance 401k jobs everybody
else is either working for another cairo
or they've tried to open their own spot
how did you open up your first place is
that what you did right after college so
i worked for a corporation in texas
first for a couple of years and so
uh what i wanted to do was learn the ins
and outs of treatment and i actually
worked in middle management too to kind
of figure out how the brokers worked on
negotiations and things like that
but not on my dollar
i didn't want to learn on the job on my
dollar so i kind of set up a lot of
practices for them i worked in several
family practices so i worked you know
underneath medical doctors in a lot of
offices learned how to get referrals
from them learned how to communicate
with them and then after a couple years
of that that's when i opened my spot so
my first my first job and and so let me
rewind that so obviously flat broke
coming out my parents had saved a decent
amount of money for me you know 50 60
000
for college
i had a scholarship all the way through
undergrad so i didn't know anything from
there and then they helped apply that
towards my grad school so i didn't know
much like maybe 40 grand i think yeah
this is 12 years ago it's much higher
now obviously with
um inflation
thanks jerome that's the magic word yeah
everybody's favorite jerome powell
so i only owed 30 or 40 i think coming
out so i paid that off in the first two
years i just kept living like a student
the whole time
um so i had about 30 or 40 000 saved
when i went to start but i didn't work
for maybe five months so when you don't
have any income coming in and you're
living on that it goes really quickly so
my first office that i owned
i had a friend that owned a building and
i negotiated he didn't make me pay the
first and last i was paying 500 a month
for a one-room suite in the in the hood
in albuquerque
and then uh i built everything else
myself i got a table from a guy
on ebay
my office equipment was a family friend
that had had a stroke and so i bought
his you know office furniture for really
cheap obviously painted the office
myself and i didn't i couldn't afford
staff so i had to build a website so i
was doing online scheduling 10 years ago
uh built the website on wix
it's cool didn't have a phone line yeah
uh because then you have to pay somebody
to answer the phones
worked on wristbands you know way back
in the day to where we're just linked to
the website so if i was at the gym and
somebody was like hey you know i'd be
like boom here you go and they could go
schedule so it just really ran super
super lean for i mean i still do but for
the very beginning of it so i could
accumulate my own bank account to where
i could buy equipment as we needed yeah
so how much were you making back then in
those lean days i think my net probably
my first year was 25 or 30k okay um you
know going up about 30k per year until i
started hiring other therapists and then
getting you know a percentage of their
revenue so now we have 13 therapists
um
so essentially their my their fractional
income kind of replaces the volume of
patients i used to see because i don't
see any patients and i haven't for three
years or so
um so now we've got five clinics we have
one in vegas one in boca raton three in
albuquerque
and um yeah it's it's it's been nice
social media really propelled us yeah
anything
um we're not spending money on
billboards or you know radio ads or
anything like that
you know yes and even when we started
when i would sponsor fighters who were
notoriously broke you know we'd say okay
what is your sponsorship worth is it
worth 8 treatments is it worth 10
treatments well put us on your shorts
you know get us on ufc countdown or you
know those things and we'll call it a
trade and
say they have 300 000 on you know
instagram or something like what would
you pay to reach 300 000
probably more than 200
oh yeah so
you know and you're getting who says
other than you somebody who's beating up
their body more than anybody else right
so it was a perfect mix for us um you
know working with mma fighters because
nobody beats their bodies up more than
they do is that how much it costs is
about 200 of treatment um in in nevada
our price point's a little higher than
new mexico so to see one of my neighbor
paths here it's 150 for a new patient
and i think it's 100 for follow-ups each
session is about an hour or so they
average about four total sessions until
they can resolve you know most
treatments is this something you
recommend like a healthy person get done
on a regular basis like if they don't
get beat up so i'll tell you that we
don't treat anybody who's not in pain
okay so
we're not the type that promotes it as
like a wellness plan sure to me when i
look at somebody if they don't have
anything wrong with them no pain which
which is rare like who doesn't have some
neck pain or whatever right um there's
only one way you can go and it's you
can't get better than no pain you know
so we i've had people try to come and i
said no no we're not going to treat you
um i generally also don't treat people
over 65 i don't treat people under 16 or
so yeah um you know because there are
people in those fields that specialize
in geriatrics or pediatrics and that's
not me so you have to kind of know what
you're good at what you're not you know
we treat musculoskeletal pain at our
office and that's it we don't do
nutrition we don't sell you know
supplements we don't sell pillows
um we try to hedgehog principle it and
we try to be really good at one thing
and then we can refer everybody else out
yeah now have you noticed uh like a
commonality between people who use
certain type of pillows or certain type
of mattresses that they have more pain
than others not really really yeah
everybody always asks me that and i'm
like i don't know yeah what's your
pillow recommendation i don't know i
don't have like a casper a mattress i
don't have a sponsor right now either
you know so
uh you know generally speaking most
people do better with less pillow and
sleeping on their back as far as like
neck and shoulder pain
i i've been thinking jack is crazy for
that they call me a psychopath yeah i
sleep without a pillow i said i said i
jokingly said that once and now i always
call jack a psychopath yeah i sleep
without a pill it's fantastic yeah so it
was weird do you not like sleep on the
side of your head you just sleep like
this like a zombie no well so recently
i've been switching the hands up and
then what no are you serious oh you're
actually look at him he's nodding see
wherever people can sleep well you know
i'm a fan of that yeah that's strange
why is that strange i put a pillow on
top they're not waking up in pain and
they're not getting like blood flow
restrictions then that's imagine imagine
a girl
that's what i'm thinking you're not
getting lying
and then you're getting a little
compressive soft force here the
compression is on my forehead comforting
really nice yeah i love it so our body's
great compression to a certain extent
that's why everybody likes to use those
compression boots and things like that
you know the the intracellular pressure
of your body is always kind of pushing
outward and the air is matching it right
like yeah and this opens you up too like
if you're like this your arms are too
close to your legs at your sides yeah
you know what i got uh this right here
basically got me a weighted blanket
weighted blankets are great i love
yeah i've never been a fan but even in
the heat yeah yeah even in the heat
though i turn on the air conditioning
and just so i could put the weighted
blanket it's it's nothing magic man so
weird cold in the room to where you're
snuggling with the stuff
but even if somebody just kind of holds
your arm or compresses your forearm even
just a little bit of pressure it feels
good to us and you know we're social
beings we're
you know hominids so
we respond to social cues to facial
expressions we
respond specifically to touch so just
having somebody touch you studies have
shown decreases your serum cortisol so
just somebody just holding your hand or
touching your forearm or things like
that so we respond to pressure um more
so from other humans but also from you
know inanimate objects so i'm a back
sleeper i get one of those like body
pillows that has a little beads in them
and i hollow it out to where there's not
much there because if i sleep on you
know we're at the encore and i laid on
my back on the pillow and i wake up my
neck hurts it's pushing my spine forward
right so i would tell you what you want
is your spine to be
lined up you don't want your head
forward or to the side of anywhere in
your spine so if you are a side sleeper
you want enough support to where you're
not here or here you know and if you're
a back sleeper you don't want your head
pushed forward got it um
our spine's pretty good here if you've
ever looked out the window for a long
period of time you know you're looking
at the grand canyon or something and you
come back you're like oh right yeah yeah
it's pretty easy to strain your neck um
so we're more fragile than we thought it
should be but what about those things
that you strap yourself into i saw the
commercials in the 90s where they would
invert you the teeters the teeter-totter
what was that the
something the old man that straps him in
yeah upside down teeter hang-ups
yeah
yeah the teeter hang-ups so again same
thing it depends uh you know like we
tell people if you do well with it keep
doing it if not then don't you know i'm
not somebody who does well with it but i
have a disease called healed germans so
i have no curve in my t-spine so i have
a lot of compression fractures and disc
herniations at my thoracic lumbar
junction the way that the pressure feels
there actually causes me more pain so
when i've thrown my back out in the past
or whatever i'm like all right let me
jump in there and see and most of the
time for me it makes me worse so you
just have to listen to your body you
know it's like being in the gym okay you
throw your back out doing deadlifts
multiple times in a row maybe that just
isn't an exercise for you maybe just do
something else modify yeah i think a
question a lot of people are wondering
is is it bad to crack yourself because
i've cracked myself since i was like
seven years old i started out my fingers
i then changed to my wrists and now i do
my neck and my back you know so i do
everything now my ankles my knees
what i would generally say is there is
such thing as over manipulation syndrome
so you know people that
they they crack themselves too hard or
too often or they go to the chiropractor
too often
what happens is so when you're getting
the n range of motion right there's
ligaments to hold it together if you
continue push past your end range of
motion what will happen is ligaments
will start to stretch out eventually and
they won't be super stable so that
causes instability which you don't want
you don't want hyper mobility but you
don't want hypomobility either so you
want to make sure that you have full
range but you don't really want to be
you know going beyond full range that's
not exactly healthy so when your
ligaments aren't aren't stable that's
what happens so as long as you're not
forcing the cracking motion like a lot i
typically get manipulated or adjusted
once every six or eight weeks or so
that's what i found is a good amount for
me when i was in cairo school or things
like that if i had it any more
frequently than that i would actually
feel like i needed it more and that
would actually have more pain as opposed
to working on strengthening and
stretching got it but first we gotta
thank our sponsor aura frames graham i
have a problem i got my dad a tinder
platinum subscription for his birthday
and he hated it and so did my mom and
also we got father's day coming up and i
don't want to make the same mistake
again jack you just get him an aura
digital frame aura digital frames allow
you to instantly frame photos from any
device anywhere directly through the
aura app you could even preload photos
and add a personalized video message
that will display as soon as you connect
your frame so i got an aura digital
frame recently and it has worked wonders
when it comes to my success on tinder
with these dates or was named the number
one digital frame by wire cutter and the
strategist and it's guaranteed to make
your dad smile or frames have super high
resolution displays so unless you look
really closely or see photos transition
you wouldn't even know it's a screen
last year aura completely sold out for
father's day so don't wait seriously
guys this is actually really awesome for
me because just before they sponsored us
i was actually looking at aura frames
exactly because they are the best in the
field you can get unlimited cloud
storage with super high resolution
screens it's a perfect gift to your
parents and it's guaranteed to make them
smile that means your parents are
finally gonna love you again listeners
can use codeich to get 20 off while
supplies last terms and conditions apply
and from now until father's day you can
save on the perfect gift when you visit
orframes.com that's auraframes
e s a-u-r-a-f-r-a-m-e-s-dot c o m so
thank you so much or frames and back to
the podcast so what do you recommend
people do who can't afford a
chiropractor well i think you know the
great thing about the internet youtube
there's tons of like mobility videos out
there for free tons of stretching videos
yoga foam rolling that stuff clears most
issues particularly chronic issues if
you're doing strengthening and
stretching and rolling you know i get
flak from this from the chiro community
i don't think people need to be adjusted
that often or it's that important for
most people um
they might disagree with that maybe
that's because of their business model
i'm not here to say either way
i know for me personally i don't need it
that frequently
and i'll say this i say like i said most
people if they do core strengthening if
they're they're working if they have
somebody to even assess them but you can
sort of assess yourself if you're
stretching doing yoga rolling getting
strength and activity walking you're
probably going to be okay
the the spot where the the kairos come
in super super helpful like i said is if
you get a rib stuck or if you jam yours
high joint we have that really sharp
pain here and you're leaning away from
it and pts can do manipulation too or
you know in the springtime like i said
you get a rib stuck and you take a
breath and it feels like somebody's
stabbing you
there's not much that's more effective
than manipulation in those certain
circumstances um it can't help of course
if you have that acute neck pain um
but yeah just it depends on the person
like i said it's finding the right fit
for everybody um like i don't do great
with massage
some people do don't do great with
manipulation so you won't really know
until you try you know no matter what
the therapy is but it's important to
listen to your body and say yeah i do
feel better or i don't feel better and
sort of tailor your life just like you
would with anything else you know yeah
has anyone ever came to you with a
problem that cannot be solved by
cracking them for like what if they came
with like a broken bone and they missed
something that used to be cracking just
like the bone was like sticking out
sticking out of the leg
like i said luckily we have you know
four years of doctoral education uh past
five or four national board exams and
state licensing exams we're trained to
diagnose and do not exams so um you know
if you're missing stuff like that that's
sort of on the provider so say i see 12
people a day at least one or two of them
i'm referring out almost every single
day
um they come in with an issue i'm like i
think you need back surgery i think you
need this or that so we refer to a
neurologist or you know or will send
back to their pcp for a bursitis
injection where they need cortisone so
really you know we work almost like a
portal of entry for musculoskeletal a
lot of people i'm like you need more
strengthening for this and a facility
that has better equipment than us we'll
send you over to pt the cairo thing is
actually not all that representative of
how our practice typically looks the
cracking stuff it's a very small part in
fact i probably only
crack maybe half of my patients
um at all
uh but it definitely films well yeah so
you know so so we post we we don't
record the boring sessions with no
cracking
i think the format of the cracking is so
unique it reminds me kind of like of
jeff's barber shop like i love the
scenarios where it's like you're doing
something else while talking to the
person
as like a late night talk show except
there's something else yeah like hot
ones i really love that format yeah and
that's sort of what we realized you know
eventually there's only so many ways you
can crack a body right so audience the
audience capture or whatever
they're gonna get bored eventually so we
were like well we have really
interesting
um clientele and people have interesting
stories to tell so since i do so much
muscle work and so i i do so much so
when i say massage what i mean is like i
don't do well with the flu flu stuff i
do really great with deep tissue massage
uh time massage painful stuff yeah my
muscles are generally tighter than they
are loose and everybody's wired
differently right so it's very rare i
need to do more strengthening i need to
stretch more i need to roll more i need
to get more body work so for me i do
much better with that and it takes time
it takes 20 30 45 minutes so during that
time it's either there's music playing
or i'm like talking in the air but they
can't really respond but what we found
is similar to you know those other
things we get a really honest interview
or response out of people because they
are feeling
uh
they don't have the programming on i
don't want to say vulnerable but they
don't have their i'm on tv i'm on a
network here's my computer program
response and i think people like that
ingenuity out of them and uh it feels
genuine and it feels like
um a format that they're not used to and
so that's been something that's helped
to keep our channel you know yeah
relevant how do you get so many
celebrities on it seems like in one
episode you'll have like five huge
people on there yeah and like they're
not even their own episode i'm like you
package them together with everyone else
yeah so i mean
really it started being an mma gym so
you know jackson's in particular in
albuquerque and you know our partners
here at extreme control there's going to
be at these mega gyms 15 20 pretty
famous ufc fighters so that's where we
start and most other athletes enjoy
fighting there's something primal dana
white talks about this people like
conflict they like to watch fighting
they like to watch wrestling um
so most other athletes are fans of
fighters and so they see the treatments
and they're like hey man i want that i
need that um so mostly they'll reach out
to me um
probably 80 of them reach out to me or
when we're doing a plug or an episode
it's somebody that's friends with
somebody else and they're like hey
they'd be a great guest for you
so that's generally how we've kind of
set those up it's changed a lot more in
the last year or so as our channel has
gotten bigger and people want to come on
you know
you know mutually beneficial collabs
they might have a book to sell you know
stuff like that it's now they're coming
to me not necessarily because they need
the treatment as much but because they
like the platform as well
so that's fine too you know who is the
most unique person that you've cracked
like like a really neat story or someone
that really stood out unique yeah like
like a change in them or just a unique
individual it's just a unique individual
both yeah so like brian shaw is like
he's the world's strongest man
competitor he's like six foot nine four
to three pounds i didn't some of them
right like i tried i couldn't even get
my arms around no
first guy it's ever been so big that i
couldn't even get my arms in and around
so we had to kind of modify that one so
from that aspect you know somebody that
tall or whatever physics matters you
know and it gives me empathy for like my
smaller providers yeah that that's how
my body feels to them sure you know man
that's that's rough
um you know that's like i said we had
some characters we had the wide net guy
oh you guys no way
yeah
so he was he's a
interesting guy um you know we're like
well i do next stuff and yeah got the
most famous neck
that is a match made back did you do
long necks
you did him too yeah yeah yeah
um that's not been published yet though
oh it's in the it's in the archives
ready to roll
um because usually yeah you know for us
we content farms so we'll go to la or
wherever um for a few weeks and then
we'll rack up 10 20 videos
um and then i go back to my life and
we'll just kind of leak them in you know
wow i have a really juicy question for
you i
admittedly
watching chiropractic videos or one of
my uh guilty pleasures
and
i notice a lot of thumbnails
um let's just say get the attention
of a lot of mail
now
is that on on purpose or
you know does it get better views i mean
you know just
so the algorithm works by recommending
you content alex that you uh
watch
that you clicked on so it sends you more
of that alex so yeah i just i just look
at something and if i like yeah yeah
well i'll say this like uh you know my
wife she commented man of culture i see
is that a comment that shows up
sometimes yeah so my wife was doing like
fitness model stuff like seven or eight
years ago when we first started dating
so you know all of her sponsored like
co-workers or whatever always wanted to
get adjusted as well so we're like let's
film it and then obviously those videos
get a lot of traction um i mean you
start overlapping i mean my demos is
probably 95 young males i mean youtube
is overwhelmingly young and male anyway
right yeah um so what are they into like
giant men they like men that look like
cartoons and they're like women that
sort of look like cartoons as well so
just like instagram anywhere else who's
who's popular it's a six foot nine 420
pound man it's a girl with you know
stuff in her lips or you know pink hair
or whatever so stuff that's visually
striking i don't think our thumbnails
look different from male to female i
think you've seen with the same face i
think uh even all the other things but
because of the intrinsic bias of the
person watching it it feels different uh
with a female doing in our mail doing it
so you're saying i'm biased i i think
you might be looking for a certain type
of content
because you know we'll have we'll have a
male model on it's got a six-pack ripped
abs and all that other kind of stuff no
shirt in the thumbnail yeah alex
does that too like the the ones that
have like
the
fit females they're definitely less rpm
cpm than
like a bodybuilding female that's
wearing the same clothes or uh you know
world's strongest fan female or
whatever
yeah a lot of that has to do with the
audience who's clicking on that video
right so maybe that audience is less
valuable to advertisers
i this on the videos that he's talking
about like we do have an overwhelmingly
amount of people coming from india
pakistan indonesia
um so i don't i don't know what that
means but you know those those videos in
wwe videos also tons from india so
obviously the cpm rpm is going to be
lower from indian viewers than it is
from
norway us
um so it just depends you know we
we pull from all those different
categories um most of them just happen
to be my wife's friends that want to
come on the channel so
uh that's probably we probably do one
female for every five guests but yeah
the comment that's like that's the
comment we get a lot i'm like i think
you're telling yourself you're not
watching my you gotta watch my guys
you know you're right i tend the ones
that get recommended to me are either
those or like mark henry like world
whatever he he's a big guy and i love
watching those so you know i i think
you're right it's like opposites so the
really big freakish looking guys
tend to get the more clicks you know
mark henry and obviously the overlap of
uh you know even even if it's a fighter
a small fighter isn't gonna get like
physically small fighter isn't gonna get
nearly the views of a heavyweight so if
i haven't gone and won it's 1.3 million
views if i have like uh you know cheeto
vera or somebody like that then it's 400
000 views and i have michelle waterson
on it's seven million views that's
interesting how much strategy do you put
into the youtube channel or the content
in general not not a ton really you know
mostly it's like people that we think
are interesting as well that you know
that we vibe with or whatever you know
we're starting to learn a little over
time there's certain videos that
the interview went so boring it's just
not worth publishing you know so we've
had a couple of those but you know this
is a new a new problem or a new issue
that we've run into and like i said i
still work a regular nine to five um you
know between me treating patients and
then running and doing payroll and
inventory so i'm curious is it worth it
for you to do the nine to five at this
point given just how big the platforms
are in your reach
like could you break down a little bit
just like how your income is between
different formats because i would assume
at this point you wouldn't be doing any
sort of nine to five work anymore yeah i
would say
depending on if we haven't had in-ad
videos or sponsors you know we're
probably bringing between
[Music]
great money yeah great money but not f
you money okay so probably between
youtube and facebook
5 600k before taxes right and uh
probably another two or 300 from my
clinics before taxes got it okay um
you know our gross is high but i pay my
employees a ton yeah so 70 of our income
goes back to our team yep you know which
i don't know any other business that
really does that but to me we're a we're
provider based clinic and a patient
based clinic so how do you keep good
staff well you got to pay them right
like you got to pay them well and take
care of them so that's what we focus on
from that so it's like i almost feel
like my clinic now just pays my taxes
for my social media yep um
but i'm also scared to death that
somebody at youtuber face could just go
pink and turn you off that's what i'm
always worried about you know well i
went all in on this game and uh you know
just one person found that they didn't
like me
and uh you know and you just never know
i i don't think it's likely for either
of us i don't think either of us are
going to get alex jones or you know
stephen crowder or any of these people
yeah to do controversial content uh
because i just don't touch that kind of
question obviously but it makes you
worried sometimes when you see that
happen to certain people or my niche
just dries up completely right like it's
like okay we've seen every crack video
and that's happened you know my friend
gregory johnson he was the first
chirotuber that really broke big
probably you know and he was super viral
for a while and um you know his his
content he's just not
getting the views that he used to get
he's getting 56k views of video but do
you think he's not innovating like he
used to probably i mean he's 60
62 years old and he hit a niche and he
has a he's a really good provider and
he's got a really a unique adjustment
and nobody had seen that before
but we've seen it now so what are you
doing to modify and stay in it and you
know i'm at a nice intersection age-wise
at 38 that you know i didn't grow up
with the tech but i'm young enough to
utilize that at a young age to where i
could sort of adapt back and forth and
that's what like so what you're talking
about is us bringing on interesting
guests and you know whether it's mark
henry or goldberg or whatever and
they're also telling you a story as well
which other channels may or may not do
so that's where actually being a social
media person as well is a different
story than just being a clinician that's
uh content happened to go yeah it takes
a lot of energy to continue to innovate
too i mean especially if you have a
format and you're in your 60s or you
just don't have the energy to do it so
it's a lot i think a lot of people at
that point just kind of accept it and
we'll move on it's not worth it you know
for him he's like five years worth of
revenue right and
a rabid uh patient population people fly
from all over the world to go see him
he has a deal with the hotel there so he
he puts him up and he sees them like
three or four days in a row so it's
really been a boon to his actual brick
and mortar business and he makes a ton
of money he charges you know probably
three or four times what i do uh but if
people are willing to pay for it then
that's what it is right so uh so he does
really really well from his actual
clinic and then he's he's training other
providers now that are going to replace
him as well so but he he didn't put all
his eggs in that basket he never stopped
treating you know
even treating new patients yeah where i
don't do that you know
um you know you may have experienced
this where you get stalkers and no we've
been good our audience is uh no stalkers
we've never been
no no no honestly no i'm yeah i'm being
serious i've never never had a single
issue but i think our audience is it
tends to be more finance oriented uh you
know into really bettering themself uh
they tend to be a little bit older
um
and i think because of that like the
people we meet are always like yo man
check out my credit card or i just saved
all this money i just paid off this debt
or i just bought a property those are
the people i think are less likely to
have the tendencies to become stalkers
i think i'll knock on wood you know yeah
and i guess that's a good point that i
hadn't really thought of is the a lot of
people that are watching my content or
pain related content are
in severe pain or you know are desperate
or and whether it's physical or mental
or whatever um are looking for something
like that and so i had one that was like
right down the street from me he lived
right there and he would leave notes all
over the place and all over town and
just you know really severely mentally
ill i had to get a restraining order and
you know it gets weird and then what i
do
like you can look at my business address
like you know where i am you know five
days a week so i'm a sitting duck a
sitting target so we had people that
would come up and they would just drive
from
north dakota or wherever and they would
show up and they'd wait for me in the
parking lot oh wow they would come up
into my they would open my door and sit
down in my room you know so we had to
take my name off the door and you know
start locking doors and adding in
security protocols and you know things
like that that stuff you never really
expect when you're like oh i'll just
start posting things online you know so
things can get dangerous for people
um especially when you're out in the
public like that you know i will say
actually it does remind me i did three
years ago
have one person this is back when i was
like actively doing real estate so if uh
if you were looking for real estate it
was easy back then to just google my
name and see my phone number who's there
um
so before i change that number
i got this one guy who kept calling and
calling and he would leave the creepiest
voicemails like creepy you told me about
this guy yeah i think i still have the
voicemails it could be you know one
o'clock in the morning three o'clock in
the morning you know 10 it didn't matter
but he would call and leave sometimes
like one to three minute long voicemails
or sometimes the first like 30 seconds
would just be breathing and then you'd
be like it's so beautiful
it's so beautiful just wait
just wait eventually you'll see it it's
amazing and but but like to do that the
entire but he would mention my name like
graham
i'm gonna show you like like stuff like
this i'm like what is he going to show
me this is like but
but it it really freaked me out and it
should um let's see if i still have it
oh wait that's my mom
[Laughter]
i want to hear that one i think this is
i'm indescribably grateful and thankful
i'm having trouble processing it all
graham it's so beautiful and precious
i can't thank god enough for my friends
it's gonna be a miracle when it happens
wow
thank you so much god
have a great day grandma i've deleted
some of them but
what do you have now 3.3 million subs or
something like that yeah no this is back
in this in the beginning but think about
this yeah if you're looking at the
general public and i don't i don't you
know i don't know what the numbers are
but say let's just make up a number
right now say four percent of people
have severe mental illness right
the the the n number the numerical
number of people that are watching your
content that have imaginary
relationships with you that really know
you
and you're their entertainment you're
not a person right you probably get this
at the airports and stuff like that
right or you're eating or you're trying
to check in and then people run up and
want to take a picture with you oh yeah
yeah yeah and you you have to be nice or
whatever but it's like dude you're
making me late for my flight like oh no
i've never i've never had a bat i've
never had a bad experience i'm a person
too you know like yeah no the word
though the worst experience i've had was
uh well it wasn't even a worst
experience it was just i remember a guy
i think i think it was with you jack
actually it was in santa monica a guy
came up really nice by the way like
anyway but he just he wanted to hang out
afterwards sure and uh
he wanted to exchange fun it was just
awkward for me because i was like you
could you know maybe an email is best or
send me a dm he's like but what's your
number like i said don't get my number
right but and it just kept like uh no
it's okay but like just give me the
number and it's just awkward for me i'm
not catching the social media right but
really nice so like no that was the
worst i've i've ever had but it's not
that bad yeah and i don't have any
actual bad ones in person like people
generally sort of know how to get along
face to face
but i mean there's some that don't
obviously and you know and i've seen it
firsthand too because i travel with a
lot of the fighters and i have for a
long time so you know there's there's
levels of real fame there's like
youtuber internet fame which is like
yeah and then there's like you know ufc
fighter jon jones holly holm name and
then there's like actor fame right like
ludacris or queen latif or people like
that where they have to have hired
security they can't go anywhere and it
makes you really
like it makes you feel for them in a way
that they're they they have to be sort
of lonely or on guard all the time
there's really nowhere that they could
go and just go shopping without somebody
getting a picture or screaming luda or
you know these people that i've that
i've met that they just and if it's
happened from a young age what's their
world experience they're 22 and they
become famous and you know it's our
fault we put ourselves out there i can't
complain if something happens because
nobody made me you know have subscribers
on the internet but me yeah but when it
starts to like interfere you know and i
guess some of these people are so rich
that they can just fly private or they
have security but imagine being
somewhere in between to where you're
you're really really well known but
you're not wealthy enough to fly private
or you know or whatever and you just
have to sit there and coach with
everybody who wants to take your picture
every single time
and you don't have anything from it
you're not saying i would i would almost
think it's it's uh
a lot of the larger youtubers would get
more attention than a big actor ksi was
the one who was talking about this it
was so true he went out to dinner and he
was sitting uh
close in close proximity to keanu reeves
who's really famous right everyone was
coming up to ksi because he was more
approachable and people felt like they
knew him as a person interesting uh then
keanu reeves who's like this big movie
star let me not bother him but ksi like
i've been watching you for years
uh it's appropriate that i come up and
say hi sure uh even for me i've i've
seen certain people out or to be like oh
wow there's no way i'm gonna bother them
but if i see a youtuber i'm like oh yeah
no i'm going to go right up and i'm just
going to say hi it's just it's something
different about it
that's because you you view yourself as
a peer in that sense like you're a
youtuber also
and you know you you know what each
other go through there's some relation
um like maybe
maybe yeah i think it would be
32. so yeah you know
if you're in an environment that skews
younger then yeah that's probably going
to be the case if you're in a upscale
restaurant or something like that with
older folks you know that's that's not
going to be the case right so sure so
just depends on your demos but yeah it's
uh things can get weird for people yeah
you know i'll tell holly holm you know
the efc fighter yeah she stands out big
strong tall long blonde hair you know
she's kind of the pride and joy of
albuquerque but she would like pull up
somewhere in her car and some guy would
come run up and masturbate in front of
her or you know people would slide
pictures under the uh the stalls in the
bathroom to have her try to sign them or
interrupt her dinner and you know
eventually that's going to wear on
somebody like that you know so it's uh
there's levels to it depends where you
are where you're not and then for me
like in albuquerque it's like okay if
i'm at the store and somebody's like hey
bo or whatever then i have to run
through my rolodex i'm like is it one of
my 20 000 patients that i'm supposed to
know or somebody that's just watched me
on facebook or youtube or something
so and then me rolling the rolodex may
look like i'm not interested in talking
to them so now i'm a jerk or something
you know and now you've offended
somebody who their only interaction with
you their entire life was a negative one
and that's obviously not a good thing i
think it's because the beard is so
recognizable that's the thing how much
how much of this was just purely for
uh just this the branding
yeah is it a lot yeah okay absolutely
uh the all blacks you know i'm yeah you
make yourself a meme at some point right
right like hey i've noticed the same
shirt the beard the red hammer yeah
yeah he's made himself into a meme well
i have a really weak jawline okay so
that was like one of the thing i'm like
well if i can get enough you know
hair growth here i can make it look like
i'm a disney villain people are like do
damn bullseyrian man
too you know alex hormozy you also have
the hairline too you know yeah yeah you
have you have immaculate hairline and
for mostly
but he doesn't really have that that
sort of beard right yeah this is
looking beard yeah okay sure yeah hit
things with it or something
yeah so it definitely stands out so that
is definitely by intent and then we talk
sometimes we're like you know maybe i
should just shave clean and shave my
head and just the amount of con comments
and things but then you're not
recognizable right where are you
investing oh boy um so i just invested
in
uh our version of the neighborpathic
school it's coming to nevada so we're
going to be opening a school here to
teach kind of what we do cool
so any in a
in a school which is a unique investment
so that's my most recent and it's you
know five ten year probably sure
um
i just you know probably like you i did
a lot of short selling early in the 2020
recession in the stock market and just
everybody made out like gangbusters so
it wasn't because i was a good investor
it was because i knew it was coming back
right that's some crypto uh
more than i probably should at this
point right luckily i wasn't in the luna
boat but you know would you buy bitcoin
ethereum i'm mostly crazy i mostly have
staked ether for the most part staked a
lot of it yeah
are you ever worried
are you ever worried that uh it might
not ever unstake yeah
absolutely yeah yeah i'm so worried
about that yes yes no nothing so for
those who don't know basically smarter
than me yeah so basically with ethereum
you could you could stake your ethereum
on the blockchain and it basically will
help facilitate transactions but and in
doing so you'll get paid what's the
interest rate like six percent keeps
dropping
yeah oh as more people stake basically
the less
they need to pay out i have to keep the
mistakes three or something now yeah so
i mean the the mindset for a lot of
people is that if you're not planning to
sell it anyway you may as well stake it
and get three percent because you
weren't planning to sell
but you can't unstake it until ethereum
2.0 comes out which has been every
single year
since like 2018 i believe
um been promised every year yeah i've
been promised every year so i'm in this
belief where it's like they said last
year's like oh 2022 the end of 2020
probably by 2023.
like i get so worried that that money
just
you don't know i mean it could be 10
years from now 15 years and what if you
need the money and i think there are
ways that you could sell
uh
but you lose a significant amount of
value in the process which makes sense
yeah so yeah i mean uh
i'm hope i'm a lot really with crypto
i'm long-term investing at least till
the next halving cycle or whatever so
i'm trying to put things in different
ranges right so like say a school is 10
and some real estate might be 20
so i'm trying to tinker some of my
returns over different periods of time
you know long term obviously tax
write-off investing in
septs and 401 k is even further than
that so
what i've been really trying to do is
hit all those single boxes so yeah i do
real estate uh
school crypto stocks
but the number one thing i invest on is
my own business you know so if if i have
extra money it's going to be going into
opening a new location buying new
equipment so stuff that can help to a
make you more money and be creating more
jobs and see create more people without
pain yeah so for the school um
how big is the school that you're
planning to to build so what we're so
we're partnering with a medical uh
university here so i'm not gonna say who
they are yet because we still need to
finalize it but so the first accredited
neighborhood school is in santa fe new
mexico so nepalese only licensed in two
states right now so we're in illinois in
new mexico
under the medical board in new mexico
and what we're trying to do is take it
nationwide to all 50 states so what that
requires is money for lobbying we've got
to get in with the politicians in each
and every state so we're looking to like
i said license here hopefully within the
next year for naper paths and
you know quite frankly the school has to
pay gross receipts and state income tax
in new mexico so nevada seems like a
much better place for corporate
headquarters for it it's going to be
easier to get students here for it as
well in santa fe new mexico which is you
know an hour from the airport and in new
mexico you know this is the center of
everybody comes through vegas so we've
got i think 38 students right now and
the goal would be to get to 200 to 300
within the next five years
and we're also going to expand into
florida next so the states that um
you know the accreditation allows
because there's a bunch of different
processes right you have to go through
accreditation for
federal student loans you have to go
through licensing for schools then you
have to go through medical licensing so
that people can have a practice act and
each one of those things requires a lot
of lobbying a lot of finance a lot of
lawyers and so um really like i said
we're trying to go all in and expand it
and then create this profession that
sort of straddles the in-between between
you know physical therapy and cairo and
massage and sort of takes the best
aspects of all those and then combines
them into one got it so you reached out
to me like uh when was it about two
weeks ago yeah what prompted you to
reach out then
was it the fight i think yeah the boxing
match okay yeah all right now now i'm a
pro fighter so now now i could get in
that way there you go yeah so now we
have another provider on on our uh
patient roles that's really cool what's
your plan to do with me because i i've
seen the videos i don't know if you're
gonna be doing the hammer or like the
the neck
what did you have in mind i was probably
going to sell you some crack on the
internet okay
all right well jackie you were looking
for that earlier right
there we go we've got a second we got a
third of course
there it is yeah yeah so we were i was
coming back through vegas and i saw that
you moved here because i definitely
watch a lot of your content as well so i
was like yeah that that seems like a
good fit
he just got in a boxing match i'm
assuming his neck is probably pretty
tight it's always tight it's always i
always i'm really uptight in my like
upper back and then i have flat feet so
my lower back when i stand too much also
hurts did you say you've never been
adjusted before never been adjusted
let me tell you the first time my neck
was adjusted
it was i i'm so excited to see graham
get adjusted and
i don't know when uh he's posting the
video but if he posts it we'll link it
down below because it's going to be a
sight to see
so i've seen the one where you did you
did the thing and they get the the neck
range and you had her like move her neck
and then you cracked it and she could
like move her neck all the way around
like the exorcist right
are you gonna do that to me yeah
probably really yeah wow does it make
you feel
uh nervous and excited that sounds like
the right question because i yeah i hate
pain
obviously but uh
you know i i mean more than there's
something people that don't hate it
obviously yeah that's just like
their stories
it just
it just seems like uh anyways there's
people that are into spooky i don't know
probably yeah looking at the stores that
i'm driving by and i'm like
i got a funny chiropractor story so i've
never been adjusted but i have been like
rubbed you know how they like rub your
muscles really hard i had an i.t band
injury back like junior year of high
school and i went in
i actually went to the emergency room
first and i got x-rays because i thought
i broke something turns out i didn't
they sent me to the chiropractor and
they like rubbed my my it band a bunch
one of the most excruciating pains i've
ever felt in my entire life that wasn't
an adjustment or anything right but then
afterwards after this like huge probably
took like 20 minutes of rubbing terrible
they sent me to this other room and they
attached these little stickers to my leg
from like my hip all the way down to my
ankle and these stickers send electrical
impulses to your leg to like shock it to
stimulate the muscles and to get oh does
it cause it to like see
yeah like seizing up and convulsing and
stuff like that and then they wrapped it
in this huge like freezing pack wrap so
my entire leg was like all casted up
basically from the hip all the way to
the ankle and this guy spent let's say
like 15 minutes getting it all ready and
then he left the room and immediately
once he left the room i looked and it
was the wrong leg no no
yeah no way you didn't notice it was the
wrong one it was just the wrong leg no
yeah that he set this in like he rubbed
out the right one because it was
incredibly painful right but as soon as
you sent me the room for these wraps and
everything just the wrong legs was it a
different person doing the wraps or was
the same part no it's the same person
and i and i was like excuse me is this
in vegas no this is uh socal okay yeah
and i remember i kept trying to call out
from like i was like lying down my leg
was getting shocked excuse me please
come back
and they just kept going oh no and then
it was the most awkward thing that i've
been deliberating in my head i'm like do
i tell him so we can do it to the right
leg or do i just leave and act like it
didn't happen and then they came in
after i did the whole treatment it was
like 20 minutes or 15 minutes or
whatever they came back and excuse me
i'm so sorry but you did the wrong leg
and it was just like a total facepalm
moment it was it was yeah
something yeah so they
they they did it yeah they put it on the
right leg and uh through probably four
sessions of just like intense rubbing
and everything like that and the
shocking it actually fixed it right yeah
terribly painful right i did the injury
for like two months so yeah it was
pretty bad yeah i've had i've had i.t
band syndrome it's brutal terrible not
fun yeah starts out in the upper thigh
and then just moves down to the knee and
that's where it really was i was 5k for
a while i had that and then they had to
get in there and break it up and mine
was i was a runner too yeah yeah
not fun at all but it works yeah um yeah
it's it's crazy that you say that so if
anybody's ever so some of our rotations
we actually go and watch surgeries um
and then you know i'm friends with a lot
of orthopedic surgeons so they'll let me
sit in because we do cadavers in school
but we don't watch surgeries so for us
to have a better idea of what our
surgical friends are doing it's really
cool to be able to go in there and watch
orthopedic surgeries and things like
that to watch the tissue in real life
and in the joint
but every time there's a procedure i
think i don't know how many have to come
in several doctors have to come in and
mark the lag and they mark it over and
over again because obviously this has
happened so many times over the history
of you know surgical procedures and you
know shocking the wrong leg is annoying
but it's not the same as like doing an
acl graft or something on the wrong leg
right or
god forbid an amputation yeah i was
about to say they amputated the wrong
foot that's just how
the man holy many times right so they
they really go overboard now because of
the consequences of that the lawsuit
would probably just be yeah oh gosh yeah
i mean yeah you see you see the
you know
people and again they're humans right
but you know they leave a sponge in or
they leave a scissors or something i
mean leave a sponge inside yeah it's
happened you know um yeah i've seen so
many youtube videos where like the the
mystery illness where they get really
sick all of a sudden they don't know
what it is and you know they're at the
brink of death and then it turns out
that like the doctor left the sponge in
10 years ago and it got infected over
time or it dissolved and like crazy
things uh there's some i've even seen
where they've left yeah like you
mentioned equipment in there so um yeah
you know so we're supposed to learn from
our mistakes and so obviously the the
more time goes on the more
precautionary procedures the more people
come in and check and all those kind of
things because they're humans right just
like everybody so they they make
mistakes unfortunately the consequences
some people you can't just have mistakes
right like the gardener he trimmed the
wrong you know hedges or something like
you can't have a pilot that didn't land
the plane right you know so depending on
the consequences of the procedure like
there's just you have to double triple
quadruple check yeah those things if
they make my ice cream sunday wrong it's
not that serious no this wasn't a big
deal i i was just nervous because i
didn't want to be i felt bad because my
god you spent all this time wrapping my
leg and you didn't at any point say that
you just speak up a little bit i mean
they come to your business
did they at least copy your visit and
give it to you for free no
no i still paid i honestly it wasn't a
terrible feeling it's kind of a unique
sensation i wouldn't call it pleasurable
but like getting shocked in the cold
sensation and whatever yeah it wasn't
bad so like in our office like in our
motto's results matter so if if there's
somebody that we can't help like i have
to send them like most people i know
right away like i'm like no man you need
back surgery let's link you up with
somebody
um you know or or whatever we're going
to refer them out to or if i do a full
treatment on them and nothing has
changed at all it's very rare that i'm
going to find something because i spent
an hour with everybody right that
magically i'm going to have a
breakthrough on the fourth session or
something so we're we if we don't get
the changes at least 50 75 percent that
we're looking for we we comp the visit
like you know to me it's like you have a
stake and they mess it up right you
would expect for it to be free or them
to replace it yeah you know healthcare
is the only thing that they can sort of
mess it up and then just still charge
you for it you know just
um you know if their car was damaged you
could take it back or something like
that right so
it's something that's always bothered me
about healthcare is that if something
doesn't work
right you get a surgical procedure done
or a medication or whatever like
why
why am i not getting my money back this
didn't work
um that's a good take you know whether
no matter what it is like oh it's a ten
thousand dollar stem cell therapy or
something you're like okay cool and then
you get it done you're like yeah i don't
feel any better like tough you know
there's no other fields that you would
your product would fail on you that you
wouldn't you know be able to send it
back or get a refund or something yeah
and so that's something we've you know
we've always tried to incorporate is
that this is a customer base and like i
said a provider base so their feedback
is what matters if they don't think
they're better than they're not right
yeah so it doesn't matter what i think
you know what i absolutely hate about
healthcare
not to get into it but um i hate how you
can never know what something is gonna
cost
yeah why can't i go in and just yeah why
can't i go in and just be you know they
tell me i need this and then i'm like
well how much is it going to cost and
then they
they don't tell you like i i don't know
why do you i know
chiropractic is a little bit different
um but do you know why there's there's
such a such a
fog i guess in the field in terms of
pricing so so cairo can be different and
sometimes it's not it depends on the
provider how much insurance they're
taking or you know if they're doing
personal injury or whatever there's a
couple components one is that there's a
social stigma about doctors talking and
nurses talking about money for their
patients
um even though you take enough to do no
harm that also means do no financial
harm so you should always try to find
the
you know the most affordable care for
them as well
um
unless there's an alternative right
so
they'll they'll just kind of pass you
off and you have to deal with the front
desk staff whose job is to be the pit
bull and to fight for the money and i
just don't think that's a an acceptable
situation because the front desk person
doesn't know the medical procedures they
don't know the terminology so you're
you're really creating a barrier and i i
just think it's a
cultural stigma the doctors don't deal
with that kind of stuff and you can ask
a doctor and they'll basically never
tell you
you know this oh it depends what your
insurance will cover all the front desk
will you know it's an uncomfortable
conversation and maybe it has to do with
the fact that you're dealing with a
person's body and you're putting a price
so yeah on their body
like i need a liver well you know that
well our liver is uh 750 000 if you want
that but we have a deal going on right
now if you get uh the pig liver instead
of special 150 000 on this one it's
experimental uh or yeah it's it's just
bad soon but i think offer expires you
gotta say yes next five minutes though
but i think people deserve that
transparency right because the fact of
the matter is that it is a financial
decision you are making financial
decisions it's the number one cause of
bankruptcy right so people are going
bankrupt they're getting this huge bill
in the back of the mail they can't
contact people they're sent to
collections and they didn't even know
what the procedure would be they don't
know what in in network or out of
network means they don't know what cope
they don't even know what co-pays mean
you know they're like oh i have
insurance and then they assume they're
going to be covered and they get a 40 50
000 bill we need to do better in all of
healthcare so in our business our prices
are right there on the website right
there's never going to be an upcharge
down charge this is what it is if you
want shockwave therapy it's 40 for 30
minutes right if you're getting
orthotherapy it's going to be 90 for an
hour that's what it is period if you're
getting just the spinal alignment it's
40
um
so people our patients know what the
price is and then you know after my
first session whether i charge them or i
don't we say i think this is going to be
about four sessions five sessions
whatever that's going to be and then we
target that so we don't obviously take
the money up front but they have an idea
if they want to keep going forward what
this is going to cost it's going to be
360 dollars for us to resolve yes right
and if along the way this isn't working
for you then we send you somewhere else
yeah but then they go there and they go
to some outpatient pt and turns out
their deductible is 6 000 and they get a
you know a 500 bill on their first visit
that's just an eval and then they're
like well why'd you send me there i'm
like well that's the care you need but
they they're out 500 with no improvement
and it's not the pt's fault necessarily
maybe it's the organization but you know
i think is healthcare in general we need
to do a much better job with
transparency financially for people
especially given what the cost to our
economy is financially from healthcare
yeah why is so much medical care so
expensive though because my
understanding is that they just bill
really high expecting the insurance
company to negotiate it down and like
that's the only reason why well there's
a lot of components of that so the one
thing you mentioned right after that
there's a middleman an intermediary and
they have a lot of salaries to pay for
along the way as well so an insurance
company is designed to be profitable
even though they're really not they're
subsidized a lot by the government um
but they have a lot of admin they've got
to pay and they've got a lot of people
that are making phone calls they've got
to pay so there's a lot of leak in the
finances that goes along there as well
that's one component right the other
component is you're dealing with so
think about what it would cost to run a
hospital imagine what the electricity
bill is you know uh your liability
insurance just for slip and fall
what you're you're paying your entire
staff everywhere and then you add the
litigiousness of the healthcare system
as well to where when people sue
hospitals or large industries it's
better for them to just settle than to
take this all the way to court or damage
their public opinion you know for small
providers like us we'll just bankrupt
the company and start over again we're
not going to deal with that but if
you're a large
hospital or something like that you're
just going to basically pay people to go
away or shut up and sign an nda so that
cost is passed back on as well whether
it's
it should have been settled or it
shouldn't
i'm not there to decide that but that's
a cost they'll argue that r d is a big
part of that as well that it costs a lot
of money to come up with a surgical
screw or cost a lot of money to find the
right titanium blend or the cost to
develop a drug
so that money should be built back into
the equation well and i'm not sure
they're wrong necessarily i'm a devoted
capitalist in general but i think
there's a couple places where socialism
is a better fit and to me i think that's
actually
for health care that people have to have
and i think for education i don't think
that unfettered capitalism um
in those two areas that make society
better is the best idea that you know a
college could just keep running up the
tab and could cost you a million dollars
a year
with no guarantee that this degree will
lead you anywhere
and then it's just between you and the
federal government you know i think
healthcare is another thing that you
don't you're not entitled to somebody
else's labor or time which is sort of
what healthcare is right these doctors
went to school for 12 13 years so they
should be compensated but
i think this the problem is cyclical so
here let me let me rewind this whole way
yeah so they're just expanding this now
so going back to medical school they can
expand more medical students they don't
like nurses like they can't get into
nursing school even though we have a
shortage
um
so there's medicare pays for residency
placements they pay salaries for
residency placements medicare doesn't
have a ton of money right it's
essentially bankrupt there's not a lot
of money there so they're paying the
salaries for the resident doctors that
are making 50 70 grand a year so they
can't expand more spaces even though our
population is growing so these medical
students graduate med school and now
there's no places for them to match into
residency so because of that the medical
schools don't want a ton of graduates
graduating they can't get placed in the
residency and sitting there so they're
going to have to cap how many students
they're bringing in as well well with
inflation and you know some of these
medical schools are for profit out there
uh they're going to jack the tuition up
to make up the difference because
they're not able to increase the amount
of students that they get in so it's
kind of bottlenecked on the on the far
end you know from the residency placing
programs as well so now these doctors
are coming out with three four hundred
thousand dollars i think the average is
like three hundred thousand i think in
student loan debt now at what six point
something percentages
um that they have to start paying even
though they're making minimum wage or
less essentially as a resident
um
that's going to influence some people's
behaviors wow you know even cairo's like
so i refer up for all imaging but some
cairo's have an x-ray machine in their
office right so you have to pay for the
machine you've got to pay for the osha
you got to get lead on the wall all this
other stuff
so if your patient if you're on the
fence if your patient needs an x-ray or
not do you want the bias that you're
having to pay for your x-ray machine to
be factored into your decision making
because i'm not sure how many humans
could completely separate those two
things from each other yeah right they
have medical debt they have kids in
school you know i i think as much as
you'd like to think that every single
person would always make the ethical
decision i don't think that's reasonable
to expect out of every single person so
when you settle doctors with 3 400 000
student loan debt like i think that
incentivizes certain types of behaviors
i think it pushes them to
types of procedures that are cash based
whether they're botox or you know stuff
like that and away from medicaid paying
for family doctors or for pediatricians
or people like that what's the solution
to that it just seems like uh maybe the
canadian system is a little bit better
where they have higher taxes but
healthcare is available to anybody on a
on you know first come first serve basis
is there something that you would
suggest that might make it better i
don't know i think just like anything if
there was an easy solution we'd have it
like is there an easy solution
immigration
no you could see both sides so i think i
think for wealthier people there's no
better place in the world you can get
healthcare than the united states of
america you know in canada you know if
you want something outside the system uh
you're gonna have to wait a really long
time yeah you know also canada is a
significantly much less demographically
diverse country uh economically and
ethnically and religiously so i think
those countries that have small
populations and lots of money they're
able to do things that
bigger countries like the united states
or brazil can't do you know new zealand
and canada and some of these places
norway that we compare i mean you're
talking about that's yeah you know small
countries low population homogenous
very wealthy
you know you don't see areas like
detroit or new orleans or baltimore even
albuquerque and norway or new zealand
you don't have that wealth disparity and
there's a lot of people that fall into
those categories and how do you take
care of them again i don't know i don't
know what the answer is i think the best
innovation and technology and all those
things come from the united states for
the most part
some of that is because of capitalism we
incentivize researchers to create you
know brand new uh robotic surgeries or
medications or things like that because
capitalism is incentive by nature right
like you you're gonna fight for the best
product but there's a downside to it
what's a better solution i don't know
like democracy has problems right do we
think that the most amount of people
should be making decisions i mean that's
sort of how the the sale in which trials
happen right that's how you know a lot
of the horrible things in history have
happened because more people said that
it was okay right uh but what's a better
system than that i don't know nobody's
come up with a better one so i don't
know we need reform and
and it could be that you fix one thing
and it creates a leak somewhere else and
most things tend to be that way that the
best laid plans don't work i just know
that in a country that's wealthy we
shouldn't have as many people going
bankrupt over their bodies of their
healthcare now circle back around you
could say hey we don't take care of
ourselves very well either so we're you
know 70 obese so we're paying a lot of
money for lifestyle medicine for
diabetes care for you know people like
me that eat a lot of processed food that
ended up with ulcerative colitis that i
have to take a medication every month
you know we're just do
we make a lot of bad decisions and that
might be a byproduct of our
american-ness of wanting to do what we
want of having lots of money to where we
can smoke e-cigs all day or you know
whatever that is that we know is bad for
us but we still do it
um that we end up having to pay for
those lifestyle behaviors and activities
down the road right i don't know like we
we should know better but we still smoke
we still gamble you know as a society we
still make things and decisions that
that are harmful for us that um
that are going to cost us down the line
so then what is it we authoritarianly
don't let people do those things and
freedom is important too right like
freedom to choose what you want to do
with your healthcare i think is really
important
um you know in in ebm or evidence-based
medicine there's three components
there's literature there's the
clinician's you know intent or or
recommendation and there's the patient's
willingness to be a part of that so if
the patient doesn't want to do it it's
not evm
so they have to be part of that they
have to buy into the treatment they have
to buy into
whatever it is which requires freedom do
we force people to eat certain types of
food because we know it saves us money
as a country i think it's a very
slippery slope to go down that's really
interesting that was really well said i
didn't expect like that good of an
answer agree i agree completely i heard
everything oh my gosh like what do i say
like
yeah what can i say
yes
i agree uh i do see though that we are
making progress in that in terms of like
getting sodas out of elementary schools
or putting water and just healthy uh
healthier alternatives i know i remember
it was it was a huge thing when
mcdonald's was starting to serve like
salads and fruits instead of fries and
things like that that i think are at
least setting us on the right trajectory
yeah but i don't think so a lot of those
things i think they've pulled back away
from over time because they're just not
popular and
um we incentivize
i mean even just look at a fast foods
structure of how they make money they
make money selling large sodas right
like so they they offer you it it
doesn't make sense that you could get
10 15 chicken nuggets for 99 cents
they're losing money there they have to
pay for their real estate they have to
pay for all the people working there
their insurance the cost to ship the
chicken there the actual chicken
themselves how would that ever be
possible to sell that much food for 99
cents well a couple things right real
estate is their business for one and two
they're they're making a bunch of money
on cheap foods like fries and drinks
that's what the business model is
predicated on a lot of those businesses
so either the business folds or that's
the food they keep giving so we have
this idea of food deserts and places
like that where people it's expensive to
buy a salad
some of that's caused by the economics
of it that
wealthier people tend to be skinnier and
more health-conscious because they can
right if you're not working two jobs and
taking care of kids by yourself you have
the luxury of spending time in the gym
or spending time you know finding
healthier foods so there's an economic
component to it as well that we always
blame people for being fat or whatever
but also like is it because i've also
heard that uh and i've seen breakdowns
on how healthier foods could actually
cost less
than eating at fast food restaurants
assuming
you're able to buy those foods in bulk
and just spend 20 minutes every few days
cooking in bulk yeah it makes sense you
should be able to and i think that like
we just said like wealthy people are
willing to pay more for it right right
so they can they can charge more because
capitalism will allow that
it's like the argument about like
veganism like on average vegans are
healthier than non-vegans correct
everybody's kind of looked at the data
longevity heart disease yeah
is it because they're vegan maybe but
also you have to take into account the
fact that they're a vegan means they're
probably not eating processed foods
they're probably not smokers because
they're health-conscious by nature they
probably exercise a lot their bmi is
lower there's so many other factors that
we could just say it was this one thing
or this one thing but everything is
multi-factorial so we're talking about
is demos income conditioning uh
marketing what's been marketed to you uh
these are these companies for sure make
food addicting right like it's in their
best interest to have colors did you see
the second um the super size me guy oh
uh the second one where he made the
healthy chicken restaurant i saw the
first super-sized man i figured what was
his name anyway i can't remember yeah
the second one basically what he does is
he he shows you the industry of fooling
people into thinking they're getting
healthy food so he would buy free-range
chickens which these are all legal terms
so in in this movie free range just met
that like the end of the container oh
it's so bs yeah had to have like a
little thing that got some light like
two percent yeah and i think a lot of
those were like they could turn around
in their cage with like that was free
range it's so sad so people think of
them on a farm just like with the one
caretaker like ah yeah that's bad yeah
so his whole business is he creates a
fried chicken restaurant that is able to
market in a way that's healthy so
instead of calling it fried it's it's
like
grilled crispy or something like that
yeah and they actually physically put
like grill like pink grill marks onto
the fried chicken and then the interior
part they put like you know pretty green
and vegetables everywhere but there's
actually not any vegetables on the food
oh my gosh they just use all the words
and terminology free range organic
so he gets a lawyer to help him he's
like oh yeah this is organic da da da da
said this and this
and uh no steroids and it it's through a
certain time period and basically he
creates this like really unhealthy food
but it's super easy to trick everybody
into thinking it's a it's a healthy food
product by using all the buzzwords wait
so for the steroids when they say it's
steroid-free you could technically say
it's steroid-free if you didn't give it
steroids within a certain
time frame i'm not sure about it yeah
there was something to do with that that
just like everything there's a legal
definition and you're like okay well
that's income that's not income or or
whatever right so the smartest people
are always going to find those loopholes
and figure out ways to work around those
words but essentially almost all health
healthcare products are sort of doing
that as well they find words that people
associate with health which also
explains why when you go to a whole
foods or something like
the way that people look isn't much
different than they do it i don't know
kroger or something yeah right like it
feels more open and happier and there's
produce over here or whatever but like
if you look at the nutritional info on
some of these products it's really not
any different it's just they found a way
to market in a way
which is why i don't think we've made
much progress i mean if you look at the
data you know like you were saying okay
we've got some apples or salads or
whatever sure it just doesn't the data
doesn't really
show that over a long period of time
what do you think it's going to take to
move us in that direction or do you
think it's just people are going to be
people if something tastes good they're
gonna do it i think you have both right
i don't think you can legislate your way
to behavior overall i think you could
put up
blocks in some ways you know but i don't
know i mean the thing is we all say
we're gonna die but nobody lives their
life that way right
we sort of know that but we don't really
live that way it's hard for us because
we've always been alive in our own minds
like what were you doing before you were
born i don't know what are you gonna do
when you're dead i can't even imagine it
all i know is my my worldview my life
experience it's like imagine a color
you've never seen before right you can't
so we just sort of move along through
what we call time space we're just kind
of gliding and um
things start accumulating injuries
health problems and things like that and
then we're always going to get to it or
you know
homo sapiens or procrastinators by
nature we're energy preservers so it
seems to me that what we're seeing now
is everybody sort of has access to be
unhealthy and they select few people
whether it's neuroticism or
the way they were raised sort of just
don't want to be that and they're
choosing not to and they're doing things
to not do that but it's
it's obviously very difficult if it was
easy everybody would be shredded with a
six-pack um you know like when coveted
was going on everybody's like oh obesity
is killing all these people and
and it's like you don't think people
that are overweight know they're
overweight they're aware they know that
they should lose weight but what what
can they do to
do something about it they've tried i
promise you they've tried you know
sometimes it's the early stages i think
a lot of it is as a child
you know i was pretty lean until i got
to college and then i really started to
put on weight to try to play with
linebacker and i gained a lot of fat
and i kind of got a set weight of about
220. so
i created a bunch of new fat cells and
when you create fat cells they don't
really go away they fill up or shrink
down with fatty acyls
so it takes a lot of energy to create
new fat cells so if you've never been
fat it takes a lot of energy to get
there but once you've already been heavy
it's very easy to get back to your set
weight
so for years i had stayed under 200
pounds and all it takes is just eating
sort of normal foods that everybody else
does
but the my body will just take those
those calories and shove them right back
into my fat cells and i'll gain six
seven pounds back in a week which you
wouldn't think is physically possible
you definitely couldn't create new fat
cells in that amount of time but your
body can reload the cells you already
have which is why you know you see
people have to get gastric bypass or
um
you know fat removal procedures and for
somebody that's never lived that
experience they just like why can't you
do it which is why it's important to
never do it to begin with but it's
easier said than done if you're an
eight-year-old and you know like you
said you've got a single parent and this
is the food you have and your friends
are eating this food that's all you know
there's a reason why we speak english
there's a reason why people are the
religion they are they were taught that
that's what they were ingrained with as
a child
and by the time you're 14 if you've
already had that weight how are you
supposed to overcome that i mean it
would take the most crazy discipline and
some people can do it but most of us can
most of us are like this with everything
whether it's finances or health like we
can go in waves we'll be really good for
a while but very few people have the the
ability to stay that way all the time
how do you stick with it if i had the
answer i would look like this you know
um i've done it so for me it's like if i
do a bodybuilding show or if i have a
photo shoot
i have to have like a public
embarrassment like thing or i have to
take my shirt off somewhere there has to
be a secondary incentive for me to do it
okay so i've done i've competed in
physique a few times
and if i know i have to be on stage or
compete then i will be super rigid but
if not then i just keep procrastinating
i'm like i do need to lose weight
and i'll
i'll get after for a couple weeks and
then i'll go on the road and eat again
and then it'll just be right back
and this is somebody who's cognitively
aware
of the habits the behaviors the i know
exactly how to do it i've done it before
and i still don't even do it how much
does age uh play a factor in that
i've noticed for myself uh like let's
say slimming down a lot i have just i've
been working out since january four to
five times a week and eating so clean
and i still got the belly it's shrunk a
little bit but i remember myself at 25
that would be gone within three months
yep so i mean there's a genetic
component as well but obviously the
older we get the less growth hormone the
less testosterone we we create if you're
a female you don't have much of that
anyway so you have even less wiggle room
um
the taller and bigger you are the more
your basal metabolic rate is up you know
maintain your basal metabolic rate but
those all drop off as well so as you've
noticed like when i was younger and i
would exercise i would just throw a
salad in one meal a day and i would drop
the weight that doesn't work at all
anymore you know that's just to keep me
from getting even bigger yeah
so it's big you know it's big and um you
know stomachs shrink and and grow and
you know we even think that there might
even be
up regulating and down regulating for
certain people with insulin and glucagon
and things like that to where their
bodies so you something their cells will
actually crave it and they'll make you
want to get certain types of foods
um
[Music]
the truth is nutritional science is
really soft we just we just don't know
yeah like the baseline is calories and
calories out but everybody falls on a
spectrum somewhere different some people
are addicted to gluten some people you
know have other types of food allergies
and what you see of course in our social
media is what whatever is the most
extreme gets the most clicks you'll go
vegan you'll go carnivore you'll go
fasting all those things work
temporarily like when you only eat meat
you don't have glycogen or water to put
into your cells and so you're gonna lose
water weight like pretty quickly you'll
look better in the short term but as
soon as you add carbs they'll shuttle
water back into yourselves and you'll
blow right back to explain this to me
because i've seen this carnivore diet it
seems like it's the new trend for like
the last month joe rogan just tried it
can you explain what that is yeah people
are only eating meat and meat products
alone like no salads no vegetables just
meat yeah so it'd be one thing to say
hey no processed carbohydrates or
something like that and their argument
like liver king is doing this and uh
there's a couple of physicians that are
doing it too i think peter adia and
saladino maybe or something too and
they're they're doing things off of an
evolutionary basis they're saying plants
are designed to fight you off like
they're poisonous and they're toxic and
they create
toxins and things to keep you from
eating them and they're sort of right in
the sense but like all the vegetables we
have now didn't even exist a thousand
years ago like we bred them ourselves
like there was no kale there was no
broccoli a thousand years ago we
actually as humans we created food
species and types for ourselves to feed
masses so since the age of
recorded history we've been a grain
society before that we definitely were
just hunter-gatherers we would eat
berries and nuts and but basically since
written language you know grains were
what created civilization rice wheat
they created so much food that people
could live in these river plain systems
and then you could get specialization
right you'd have bankers and people
and with bankers you need to write
things down so we have language so
people can keep track of their finances
and who owes who what and you can get
metallurgy and you can get all these
other things because you're not just
chasing buffaloes all the time so we
really have eaten grain for at least
5000 years to a certain extent that was
a bleached flower probably not right but
the the vegetables and things we've
eaten bell peppers we've bred those
things over the last thousand years so i
would argue that that's not true for
those things those things have high
nutritional con content we've actually
like i said created them for our usage
you go in the woods you're not going to
find anything edible we can't digest
cellulose so we actually have to create
our own species also we don't have dairy
cows in nature we don't have these types
of chickens we bred these things just
like our dogs yeah they can't survive in
nature we created our own foods as
hominids over the last five thousand
years especially over the last 200 years
you know the acceleration of how we
breed chickens so they grow so fast and
they have all this meat on their pecs
their feathers don't even keep up with
their legs break but it's the only way
you can feed nine billion people is by
by doing that so
i guess the long circle back away around
we're obligate omnivores we have molars
we have canines we should probably eat
some of all those things which
cholesterol definitely is associated
with heart disease like we know that for
sure i know a lot of people want to make
that argument but you know it is a
factor just like blood pressure just
like all these other things you can eat
a lot of vegetables with low caloric
inputs so it can really help people that
are hungry they can eat a ton of
vegetables without a lot of calories
obviously fats almonds things like that
are the most calorie dense followed by
fatty meats and and carbs
um to me it seems like
i would say this i would say a lot of
people they could tinker with
a higher propensity of one macro group
versus the other and see how their body
reacts but i think what you're seeing
from people is they're eating only meat
and that's what we're seeing is yes like
the carbs bring the water steaks and
beef and yeah and we don't know the
long-term consequences of that like you
know i guess we'll see in 10 years or so
what their lipids look like but you know
it seems unhealthy i don't know why like
i've not looked into it at all it just
seems like maybe for a few months you
might try it yeah just yeah and i think
it works in the short term you know i
think you can
you know drop weight in the short term
but i don't think it's a sustainable
diet just like veganism isn't really
sustainable honestly like they're you're
missing certain certain micronutrients
that you need you know uh
it's finding your balance i mean you've
seen everything there's the zone there's
thatkins you know i would say one thing
for sure that makes us fat is adding is
having carbs and fats together like
that's probably the worst combination of
things that you can have
so um you know a donut cake stuff like
that so you have high insulin high uh
absorption from the sugar and then high
calories alcohol also so sugar and
alcohol definitely going to add pounds
so for people just getting that calories
and calories out exercising finding a
balanced moderate diet eat real food
like the less processed the better it's
going to be you know if it comes in a
bag you rip open it's probably not the
best thing for you
um but i think the extremism of the
you know those diets mike many
physicians will say that their concern
is there's going to be some serious
cardiovascular side effects from having
that much saturated fat in your diet um
the the proponents will say that's not
true that really plaquing only occurs as
due to inflammation and because
people aren't allergic to meat and to a
certain extent they're sort of right
um
you know we can pretty much eat any kind
of meat as a species we have the
enzymatic capacity to eat any kind of
meat we can't eat any kind of plant you
can't eat bark you can't eat you know
any old tree that you see yeah so they
are right in that sense we did evolve to
eat any kind of meat we can eat clam we
can eat bugs we can eat cows cats
um
in general eating that will probably
have a less inflammatory fat uh
impact than certain types of plants and
grains and things so their argument is
if there's less inflammation there's
less plaque buildup and there may be
something to that they may be right to a
certain extent in that sense
um i think jordan peterson and his
daughter are like carnivore people right
yeah i think so yeah so that you know i
would say what works for every
individual matters but i i don't think
that's a good diet to put in the the
center of the population got it
wow
i'm learning so much now
crazy yeah i did not think you would be
so knowledgeable on
that
but i'm very impressed yeah me too i
thought we were going more in the the
cracking direction and then we did
totally
if you could pick like one diet or one
thing to follow food pyramid you believe
is the best it doesn't have to
scientifically be the best that just
your own philosophy i'm just curious
what that would be uh i i'm i'm more in
the calories and calories out so you
know just looking at your age your your
size your lean mass your basal metabolic
rate and just trying to keep your
calories under what you're you know
calories in less than what you're
expending so you know try to exercise
and it doesn't you know really to me the
best cardiovascular exercise is just
steady state you know walking 20 30
minutes a day it's sustainable it's not
as hard on your joints as running and
jogging especially if you're a bigger
person
and typically people aren't so fatigued
and tired that they feel the need to go
grab something high caloric
so like me personally and this is just
anecdote but like when i've done
bodybuilding shows and i try to do
really high intensity cardio i would be
so fatigued both mentally that i
wouldn't have the willpower to resist me
having something fatty
i would just be like you know about to
faint and so then i would eat something
that i shouldn't have like a giant scoop
of peanut butter and i basically undid
all the work i did
so you have to figure out like what your
mental capacity for exhaustion and
tiredness is because everybody's just
different like what they can handle and
figure out where your exercise threshold
is for that so like for me i do better
with steady state but also i've been
doing a little more interval training
lately just just for my cardio like
actual cardiovascular health too
um
so that's just me i think most people
you know again sleep well try to keep
the light out move walk eat real food
you know aim for three four five
somewhere in their meals a day um try to
keep your processed carbs down try to
keep your your meats leaner and less red
meat than otherwise and they'll argue
that too they'll say oh you know
colorectal but the studies are there so
i mean
eating red meat three four times a day
some people might be okay but there is a
correlation we look at the data could
the correlation be because the people
that eat processed meat typically have
unhealthy lifestyles as well and smoke
and drink it could be yeah we don't know
we don't have enough data to really say
um so i don't think i answered the
question i would say moderation calories
in calories out yeah i would say that
eat any real food try to exercise
something do you have any questions for
for us
i figured that you're not gonna end up
saving my questions okay for you cool so
what who's who's your favorite guest on
here so far bark quan uh bart was
amazing i would say alex hormozy
we all say we all say alex ramosi or for
me uh houston from royalty exotics they
were both so good houston i didn't
expect him to be as
as amazing in front of the camera like
houston's someone where the camera's on
him and he just like
lights up and he
is so natural but hormozy is the same
way too so i would say either one of
those and then i would say jeanette
mccurdy was another awesome that was
that was a big milestone for us to be
able to have someone like that on
and uh you know both of us were nervous
we didn't want to screw it up
and uh you know it went so well and she
was she was amazing so i would say okay
other than you
what's uh what's another finance channel
that either you watch or that you would
recommend besides your channel besides
mine there's so many uh i would say the
my
favorite all around right now has been
clear value tax
and i love i love his demeanor i love
this the
there's no editing in this video it's
just him with some papers and he talks
for 10 minutes
i love it because it's just like no
clickbait just the facts
and uh
i really appreciate that content i watch
all of his videos so financially is
there an author or something that
motivated you more growing up or was it
more familial i just always had an
interest in it um the book i first ran
into though uh my mom had this in her
office and i went in there one day and i
picked up the book it's called the
millionaire next door and i read that
book at like 10 11 years old and that
really ingrained in me like wait a
second millionaires are driving forward
f-150s and toyota corollas and like
that's cool and so from the beginning
that's what kind of like set me i think
on that trajectory of just happening to
find that book but i was interested in
personal finance just as a kid just
saving things and so for me it started
with like coin collecting i could save
up money and like i could buy this rare
coin and just like keep it so i already
had a tendency that like pushed me in
that direction
okay so what kind of rare
rare uh currency do you have because i
have like a i have a thousand dollar
bill oh do you really how much you could
federate money yeah so i have to
confederate money too um the thousand
dollar bill is something i've always
wanted as a kid and i thought about
buying either like a 500 bill or a
thousand dollar bill and framing it i
think there's a five thousand dollar but
there's very few of them in circulation
but i think they have a ten thousand
dollar bill do you use that normal yeah
technically yes absolutely because they
can't you know
legal tender right right you wouldn't
want to yeah because they're worth more
than yeah yeah of course yeah yeah but
technically yeah you could go and be
like here's a 500 wow they would look at
you like you're that would make a great
video it's by the most totally beat up
and just see how they respond yeah but
imagine if you need to do that but
imagine i might worst fear what would
happen to me is they would look at it
all right yeah
put it in the chains all right i'll give
you hundreds back and and there's the
video like you need them to be like
what's this it's fake and be like you
gotta go to somewhere where you know
they're not keeping enough change to
where they could actually break it for
sure but just to get their reactions
because they're like this is fake or
whatever what else do you collect that's
um
gosh well cars would be the big one um
yeah i guess watches
yeah not a huge collection of watches um
pokemon cards i think i think everyone
has gotten into pokemon cards at some
point
and then the goosebumps books that i was
showing you over there i thought that
was really cool um
i would love to get into collecting art
one day i think that would be a lot of
fun i'd my dream it would be to get like
a original keith herring oh wow i think
it'd be really cool that would be cool
so not at that point yet where i could
like because even like a little postcard
sizes are like fifty thousand dollars
for like a postcard
yeah and some of these are just like
literally a pencil sketch
just you know on a on a blank piece of
paper and with his name just like
scribbled on it oh there was one i
wanted to bid on uh it went way over
what i wanted it was uh what was it the
steve jobs thing oh it was the letter he
wrote to his friend at 18 years old
and that went up at bonham's auction
and i thought gosh that someday it's
gonna be worth a million bucks right i
think it sold for four four or five
hundred thousand dollars i mean i
thought for 200 grand
250 it's worth it and you could take a
risk on that but like
500 000 i just see like that sort of
memorabilia being worth a lot of money
right makes sense yeah oh you know what
what else sold uh so the other comp to
that was steve jobs first job
application
where he filled out as all of his stuff
at like you know i think it was you 17
to 20 years old
and someone kept it
wow yeah
i don't know but you know it's it's out
there yeah then you're like okay what
what do people have of mine just in case
just in case i ever hit him yeah
um so stuff like that i love elon musk
stuff so like i got the tesla roadster
but i would love i don't know like an
early elon musk something or other i i i
think collecting just memorabilia you
know so what do you think about the
twitter acquisition stuff uh that'll be
interesting to see i think
i think he's so smart
i i
that the people maybe can't wrap their
minds around what he's doing right now
people are like oh he's just
manipulating it because he's bored i
don't think so it's not worth his time
um but like him selling off
uh a stake in his tesla i believed he
wanted an excuse to sell out at the peak
or what he believes would be
a really high valuation and he sold
above a thousand dollars a share
and i think that was genius uh and he
used it as like well the twitter poll
said so uh i'm gonna do it and he sold
off a huge chunk uh looking back at a
really good price and he's so you know
now it's 30 lower than that so he made
out well on that twitter i think uh i
think
it's a weird acquisition for him but it
could it could mean a lot of influence
that uh could help his narrative so if
he's trying to pass something i mean
to be able to shape someone's uh
perception of politics or
different views
uh could be really powerful right and so
to have someone like that take control
of twitter it's a big responsibility but
it could benefit him
um
i i just don't know about like i think
he's gonna throw the offer try to
negotiate and if they don't take it he's
going to turn it around on twitter it's
like hey like i tried to do my best uh
you know it's not worth this it's
probably going to be the bots he's
probably going to say there 10 of the
accounts are bots i didn't know this
therefore i'm adjusting my offer to this
it's a fair offer it's above what it's
currently trading at
and then if they decline that then
they're the bad guys
so do you own twitter stock no
no i remember everyone's like oh it's
easy easy to buy it now because he's
gonna buy it at 54. i'm like
so much could happen
yeah i i would be shocked if it closes
at 54.20
uh i think he would negot he'd be bad if
he didn't negotiate it we'll see what
happens but also i think his tesla stock
has to do better in the short term
the other thing too is he could be
taking some of his equity in tesla which
could be overvalued
putting it into twitter at a time where
it could be undervalued so maybe he's
trying to mitigate his risk because i
think every not everyone a lot of people
look at tesla and think oh you know how
is that compared to cisco it's still
trading below what it was 20 something
years ago could that happen to tesla i
think there's a chance of it happening
and that's that's the unpopular thing to
say
but if elon sees that or he's concerned
about it makes sense take a little bit
and put it over to twitter and at least
that's a hedge and he has a lot of
influence with twitter yeah it's
interesting you said that people may not
understand him because obviously the guy
has like genius level intellect and um
you know we were having that
conversation with somebody the other day
we were saying um
you know when you look at like a
wechsler stanford brene iq which is
which is the a tool right it's not the
tool for intelligence it's a tool
um
somebody at 140 iq is the relative
difference to an average person as the
average person is to somebody at 60 and
60 is what we can see really mentally
handicapped and they're there are some
people with like trisomy 21 or downs
that are in that you know that range in
that upper 50s 60s so the average person
trying to have a finance conversation
with somebody with you know a mental
disability is the relative difference
between elon trying to have a
conversation with an average person
it's they're never going to be able to
comprehend the nuance or the level of
detail that's being applied or discussed
there yeah and even i don't know what he
is obviously or whatever but i think
it's a fair shake to say he's probably
smarter than all of us yes um so for us
to even try to understand you know the
internal machinations or the the
long-term projections um i'm not sure
even if he explained it to us that we'd
even be able to comprehend it and there
are people that are that far
on the the spectrum that we just we
can't even keep up i would agree with
that and i think he's he's
not just the spontaneous
person just doing stupid stuff i think
there's a motive behind everything he
does and some of it i do think is
self-amusement i think he honestly just
has fun talking about things that he
enjoys dogecoin probably being one of
them he enjoys the meme he likes the
culture i think he's a lot of that
playing into it and people look for a
meaning behind it where there is none i
think dogecoin is just something fun
right i don't think he's he's sitting
back be like look i pumped the price i
don't think he cares i think he's just
having a great time he's self-amused and
uh
i i don't think there's any more to it
and i think that at some point if you're
at a certain level of of wealth or a
certain level of influence i mean i i
think some some nihilism has to creep
into a certain extent because you're
like well how much further could we even
go i mean i've reached a point where
i've accomplished everybody's goals and
what else is there i mean try to live
forever try to leave an impact clean up
the oceans you know decrease your carbon
footprint it has to be something that's
like more meta in a way
uh to to make you motivated or to
interest you i mean it's not just a
startup company or something like that
the things your dopaminergic response
requires so much more stimulation and
that's either melting down twitter or
getting in a fight with the sec
or you know
creating a tunnel company i mean so this
is like you said there's some level of
amusement and the nihilism i think that
like you realize and this happens even
at the high iq levels people realize
that like we're all be dead in 60 years
so really nothing matters at all and
like somebody's gonna have to figure
things out and so for some people they
just check out they're like why would i
do anything you know and to other people
they go oh there's no pressure because
nothing really matters anyway so i'll
just really have a really awesome you
know kick-ass life and and then you have
everybody else that can't imagine that
everything is super important and it's
like dude like 99.9 of everybody that's
ever lived is already dead you know they
were having the same conversations about
some horrible thing that was happening
800 years ago and it was the end of the
world now nobody's even has record of
what they were talking about and that's
that's where we are in the sphere too
it's important in our lives but in the
grand spectrum nothing we really do or
say sort of matters and if that's the
case then like let's troll everyone
let's let's make memes or whatever yeah
and i feel like when you're at that a
level of intellect and b level of wealth
i can't
me having some trolly nature's in myself
i can't imagine what i would be like if
i was at that level i think a lot of
people would do the exact same thing
especially i think with the real
customers no for the for for him in the
sec i find that amusing because he's
taunting them and then and the fines for
him so what like 10 million bucks that
that would be like like a normal person
be like oh hey you got to pay me 5 cents
right now
and you know
you just pay it just just to be able to
taunt a little bit i think he gets a
kick out of that yeah i agree uh so it's
it's entertaining it makes uh it makes
twitter not as boring as it usually is
most people just raging at each other
about everything yeah i guess they're
raging at him somewhat now but it's uh
to have him not raging back is somewhat
interesting right i don't know i put a
lot of faith in him i have a lot of
trust in him um
some people don't but uh i'm really
looking forward to see whatever he does
whether he buys it if he doesn't
um it'll be interesting to see so do you
have doge uh i have a little bit of doge
that i bought a year ago for a video
that's down 80 percent
it was it was one of the videos i did on
dogecoin where i said if you like the
video for every like the video gets i
will invest 10 cents into dogecoin and
how many likes did it have
i don't know is there a cap at ten
thousand oh maybe no maybe it was maybe
what oh there was a cap yeah i bought
ten thousand i mean that's so yeah so
about ten thousand if it gets x likes
i'll buy ten thousand of doj i think it
was what it was oh maybe that was it
where essentially every like is worth
like 10 cents i did that
so you're huddling yourself yeah and i
said um i'll hold it for a year okay the
year's probably been up actually come to
think about it i'm not going to sell it
down so much i mean at this point i may
as well just keep holding you can't you
can't uh you can't harvest
crypto losses at the same extent you
can't stocks correct i don't know if you
could harvest crypto against stocks you
could harvest crypto against crypto
so i could but like i'm basically at my
cost basis or slightly below for bitcoin
um i'm
basically at my cost basis for ethereum
so there's not a lot to harvest there
right
so
yeah i could probably just sell
everything and rebuy it back in and at
least set everything the same because i
have some lots i bought way lower some
lots higher so i could but if you're
gonna do that move to puerto rico before
you do it right uh well for crypto i
wouldn't don't sell and rebuy it yeah
well for crypto it wouldn't matter
because if my cost basis is 30 and some
i bought it 40 somebody bought for 20
it's like
it's going to balance out it's going to
be the same thing there's no benefit so
so you're not going to join the paul's
in puerto rico no who's the other dude
uh mr gold he's always ragging on stocks
and everything just by gold
oh peter schiff yeah oh peter schiff
yeah
seems like it would be interesting but i
feel like uh it would make the podcast
this podcast you couldn't do it in
puerto rico like
the it's easy to get people in vegas
right because it's like people travel
here naturally right a big community
here and anyone in the in the u.s
you want to come to vegas for a weekend
everyone says yes puerto rico is like
you want to come to puerto that's a big
trip that's a big commitment and what is
there to do there besides come on the
podcast
so this business wouldn't exist because
of that so probably better to make money
here
uh just by having the access
make sense would you uh be the guest
referee in a michael saylor versus peter
schiff debate i don't know if i'd be
good at that but yeah sure
yeah i don't i i would say yes who's my
right
uh
i don't know i feel like you're both on
such opposite ends of the spectrum i
mean michael sailor vegan and a
carnivore basically i think the right is
somewhere in between
uh peter chef i feel like is too
conservative on a lot of financial
measures michael saylor i think
has a great long-term vision but i don't
know how realistic a lot of that is i
don't know between the two i'm probably
leaning more towards michael saylor on
the spectrum between the two but i'd say
there's probably more truth right in the
middle yeah so it's funny because time
on nutrition that's it's the same thing
almost like that's right rihanna ramsay
and uh what's his name rich dad poor dad
or whatever robbie kiyosaki yeah so
everything's extreme it's like
everything on debt or no debt right so
you see that in every sphere whether
it's nutrition finance whatever else
moderate and and somewhere in the middle
it's just not exactly it's not so i know
but it's the most right i know you know
yeah it's interesting you almost have to
take an extreme um in politics i think
is the same thing like you have to
really like alienate yourself against 50
just to get the support of the other 50
because in the middle uh i forget i
think it was kevin that was actually
explaining the the metrics of politics
to me where in the middle are like where
the most right is
there is
people actually right
those are the people less likely to show
up at rallies and turn out to vote at
all because they don't they're not
convicted enough to like to follow
through on that they're kind of in the
middle but on the extremes you get
people who show up to rallies who
support who donate who vote who are
really into it uh so you have to take
those stances uh if if that's something
you want to get into because i always
thought before kevin uh tried to meet
kevin ran for governor of california
before he did that i thought oh man it
would be so cool to run for politics
because then you could be like the voice
of reason and just be in the middle
because i see stuff on like both
republican and democratic sides that
makes sense and like i and that's why
it's so hard for me to ever identify
with one or the other because i'm like
they're right in my opinion on these
things but they're right on these things
too and if we could just merge them
together
uh but that's not what drives the
machine right right but you're gonna
sell political ad space how do you get
poor people to donate to rich people so
that they can then turn and give it to
nbc to sell you ads to make you vote to
keep this yeah and that's the thing that
that i realized is that you like have to
trigger those those emotional responses
right all the things that make certain
demographics upset i know and i actually
do i think the same person holding that
thing away from you the same thing
applies i think on youtube too it's like
if i did a video title stock market
update friday well s p is up two percent
like no one clicks on that you you you
have to stay over here yeah you have to
just what videos you click on
yeah the good ones it's a good one
great videos yeah whatever that means
but we've but we've done a lot i mean
we've done over probably at this point
well over 1200 videos and we've and so
when people you know will mention a
title they don't like a title we have
like 1200 videos of experience where
every video i sit there and watch the
analytics for an hour i know it's like i
get it
but when
the the purpose of the video is to reach
a large audience who will hopefully
enjoy the video particularly a lot of
people that maybe have not seen your
content yet correct uh you already have
your audience capture them yeah there
were notifications exactly so how do you
appeal to the type of demographic who
would benefit from that message
that demographic wouldn't click on like
how to invest in a roth ira they don't
know what a roth ira is so they're going
to click on how to be a tax free
millionaire right so
so yeah what you're talking about is
what we do
as well right so in in musculoskeletal
care like everything has its place so
surgery has its place cracking most
people need strengthening and exercises
a lot of people need stretching and soft
tissue work some people need cracking
some people need surgery some people
need injections right it's finding the
right target with the right individual
but
moderation doesn't get clicks right so
we're going to do
loud cracking videos
so the goal of course
even with our clinics is enough people
are interested in this content you
you've grabbed their attention in the
space now you get them in the office and
now you can sit there and drill on the
boring stuff sir you have to do these
exercises daily you have to spend 10
minutes a day but if i made that youtube
video if i made that instagram or tic
tac it wouldn't get any views at all and
the same thing happens the opposite so
then you make videos saying oh dr like
people make videos saying oh
chiropractic sucks or dry needling sucks
or this is why you don't need this or
that and they're reacting to things that
people are emotionally attached to so
then the incentive structure is built
there for people to be negative about
the same thing you're being clickbaity
about them right so it's just this whole
ecosystem and that again what's a better
system i don't know yeah this is human
psychology i know it's also interesting
how negativity gets way more attention
than the positivity between the two yep
so uh i've even noticed uh lately we
have a it's like not really a joke it's
more like an inside thing where it's
like down days like negative days in the
market
views are always better when things are
going really well like you could have
negative three percent
the views would be twice as much as if
we're positive three percent
and that and that's been consistent over
over five years yeah and um you know
some of that's due to our evolution
right like
this is the nature of pursuing happiness
for all of us it's a struggle we fight
our whole lives
toddlers do this they get a thing and
nobody's taught them this it's in their
dna just like lying is in their dna
right nobody taught them out alive they
just found it was more advantageous for
them to say no i don't have the remote
in my hand right they haven't learned
the consequences of that yet or the
consequences of not being intellectually
consistent you know
so
you know what you're seeing from people
is that sort of behavior that when they
get something it's the new shiny thing
right they wanted it so bad and now they
have it
the thing is they already have this so
this is their next meal this is their
next mate whatever that is
they don't even think that they could
lose this so they're already on to the
next thing and and what that is is
that's that food mentality that
home mentality you're wired to always
get the next thing because if you're
ever satisfied now you're gonna die
right if you're ever like i ate food now
i'm never gonna eat again right it's not
good for you evolutionarily you always
want the next thing the next thing the
next thing and that's just wired in
do you think that's healthy or do you
think there's there's an element to that
that uh you should just embrace it
i think you can make the argument on all
sides i think um
again i don't think happiness is a
constant process for everybody and i
don't think you ever actually find it
and that's that's why we say we have the
pursuit of happiness and it's it may be
in the pursuit of degrees or in the
pursuit of business growth or the
pursuit of x amount of subscribers but
as soon as you get the number that was
going to make you happy you're already
on to the next thing it'll never make
you happy and the people you know it's
like wall street how much is enough more
more right it's yeah
it doesn't matter um what it is and the
high achievers are the ones that are
least satisfied with whatever it is yeah
and they're just going to keep
separating themselves from the pack
whether they're you know uh
that's part of the the separation of
wealth in this country too right so
people that get more willing to risk
more or willing to to go further because
they're extreme people
um and sometimes that means bending the
rules but that's that's what they see is
their pursuit of happiness some people
their frequency is at a different level
where they're just in survival mode and
they can never get out of that
you know
i disagree with the notion that
happiness is never reached because that
assumes that like happiness is objective
based right where it's not necessary
temporary happiness
i think it's just achieving i mean new
milestones i think it's just pushing
yourself growing right probably yeah
it's different for each person but i
like to think that someone can live
their life being happy throughout it's a
mental state right it's a state of being
not necessarily like
do this be happy do this be happy
so i i we don't disagree because i agree
with you a hundred percent um and you
could find happiness and because like
you said it is a mental state if you if
instead of focusing on things you don't
have you were like man i live in a
country where i have running water and i
have a piece of plastic that can get me
food anytime i want to and i'm not in
danger of somebody running in from
another tribe and my entire family and
taking them away having that perspective
sure makes you a lot more grateful to be
here in a time where you don't scratch
your arm on a tree and die from a
bacterial infection because we have
antibiotics but it's against our
programming on our wiring to think of
all the things we have we always want to
think of the things that we don't have
which goes back to the the negativity
thing that we're talking about fair yeah
i guess we could conditioned i don't
really know about what we're wired for
so it takes a higher
frequency a higher vibe for an
individual to be grateful
it's very difficult to do and that i
think what you're pointing out is
happiness isn't that gratitude like
that's sort of what happened
wow my mom's still alive so she can call
me right but because you already have
her every day you don't walk around
every day thinking i might not have her
and our brains probably would shut down
if we sat around and thought about
everything that we could lose i mean
that's right where people have serious
anxiety or things like that so instead
we're always like how can i make more
money how can i get a nicer car how can
i get a better job how can i get a
better girlfriend and then as we age
then it's like how do i hold a lot of
the things i had how does it generally
needs to be worked towards to change
your sentiment towards that 100
and there's no reason you couldn't find
happiness in literally anything or
everything and in fact some would argue
that the high end of the iq thing it
almost predisposes you to not be happy
the the lower it is the more you're like
wow chocolate bar butterfly yeah you're
not focused on the future of the past
that's awesome well thank you so much
man i really appreciate it we'll link to
your information down below in the
description along with the uh hopefully
hopefully soon the the back cracking
video whenever you post it we'll link
that down uh as well yeah but did you
get a free stock down below in the
description when you sign up for public
using the code grant also feel free to
check out my instagram my youtube
channel you don't want to follow me
[Applause]
until next time cool